KREMLIN SPY IN GREAT BRITAIN.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE.
AMY KELLOGG IS LIVE IN MOSCOW
TONIGHT.
WE BEGIN WITH CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID
REPEATEDLY IT'S BETTER TO WORK
WITH RUSSIA THAT IT IS TO WORK
AGAINST THEM.
TODAY HE WAS FORCED TO WORK
IN A RARE REBUKE TO RUSSIA,
PRESIDENT TRUMP JOINED WITH U.K.
PRIME MINISTER THERESA MAY
CONDEMNING LAST WEEK'S NERVE
AGENT ATTACK IN BRITAIN,
POINTING THE FINGER SQUARELY AT
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> IT'S A VERY SAD SITUATION.
LOOKS LIKE THE RUSSIANS WERE
BEHIND IT.
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD NEVER,
EVER HAPPEN, AND WE ARE TAKING
VERY SERIOUSLY.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE ACKNOWLEDGES
IT WAS RELYING ON BRITISH
ANALYSIS OF THE ATTACK AGAINST
FORMER RUSSIAN SPY SERGE SKRIPAL
AND HIS DAUGHTER.
LEFT OPEN THE QUESTION WHETHER
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL FOLLOW THE
U.K. IN PENALIZING THE KREMLIN.
>> I CAN'T GET INTO THE
SPECIFICS ON POTENTIAL THREATS
BUT WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR ALLY THE
UNITED KINGDOM AND IN CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH THEM MOVING
FORWARD.
WE WILL KEEP YOU POSTED.
PENALTIES ON 13 RUSSIANS
INDICTED BY ROBERT MUELLER FOR
MEDDLING IN THE U.S. ELECTION.
TREASURY BLOCKED ACCESS TO
PROPERTY IN THE U.S. FINANCIAL
SYSTEM FOR THEM.
FIVE COMPANIES THAT SUPPORTED
THEIR ACTIVITY, AND ANOTHER SIX
PEOPLE THE USS WERE ACTING ON
BEHALF OF THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
ON CAPITOL HILL, APPLAUSE FOR
THE MOVE FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES.
>> SOMEBODY SAID MR. PUTIN WAKES
UP EVERY DAY WONDERING WHERE THE
UNITED STATES IS HAVING PROBLEMS
AND WONDERS, HOW CAN I MAKE IT
WORSE?
THIS SORT OF THING NEEDS TO BE
RESPONDED TO, NEEDS TO BE
PUNISHED.
>> SENATE MINORITY LEADER WHO IS
FIERCELY CRITICIZED THE
PRESIDENT FOR NOT IMPOSING
SANCTIONS, FOUND A WAY TO
CRITICIZE HIM FOR IMPOSING THEM.
CHUCK SCHUMER SANG THE SANCTIONS
PROVE MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION IS
NOT A WITCH HUNT AS THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES HAVE
CLAIMED.
IT'S MORE CLEAR THAN EVER THAT
THE PRESIDENT MUST NOT INTERFERE
WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION IN ANY WAY.
AT THE SAME TIME TREASURY WAS
ANNOUNCING SANCTIONS, DHS AND
FBI WARNED RUSSIAN HACKERS ARE
TRYING TO INFILTRATE THE
AMERICAN ENERGY GRID.
HAD HIS CONFIRMATION HEARING TO
LEAVE THE NATIONAL SECURITY
AGENCY, A LIEUTENANT GENERAL
PAINTING IT AS A MATTER OF GRAVE
CONCERN.
>> THE ENTIRE DEFENSE OF OUR
ELECTRIC SYSTEM IS OF GREAT
CONCERN TO ME.
I'M AWARE THIS BEEN REPORTING
WITH REGARDS TO ELEMENTS WITHIN
OUR SYSTEMS, THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD COULD CONCERN ALL OF
US.
>> IN THE OVAL OFFICE WITH
IRELAND'S PRIME MINISTER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WEIGHED IN ON
PERSONNEL CHANGES.
SHOOTING DOWN CHATTER THAT MORE
CABINET AND STAFF DEPARTURES ARE
IMMINENT.
>> THERE WILL ALWAYS BE CHANGE
BUT VERY LITTLE.
IT WAS A VERY FALSE STORY, VERY
EXAGGERATED, VERY EXAGGERATED
AND FALSE STORY.
BUT THERE WILL ALWAYS BE CHANGE.
I THINK YOU WANT TO SEE CHANGE.
I WANT TO ALSO SEE DIFFERENT
IDEAS.
>> ONE POTENTIAL PERSONNEL
CHANGE THE WHITE HOUSE IS
WATCHING CLOSELY, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S DECISION
WHETHER TO FIRE FBI DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE BEFORE HE
RETIRES ON SUNDAY.
>> THAT'S A DETERMINATION THAT
WE WOULD LEAVE UP TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS.
WE DO THINK IT'S WELL-DOCUMENTED
THAT HE HAS HAD SOME VERY
TROUBLING BEHAVIOR.
AND BY MOST ACCOUNTS, A BAD
ACTOR WHO SHOULD HAVE SOME CAUSE
FOR CONCERN.
>> THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION TODAY
WAS PUSHING BACK AGAINST A
REPORT THAT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS TAKING A NEW
TWIST BY ISSUING THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION A SUBPOENA, ASKING
FOR DOCUMENTS RELATED TO RUSSIA
AND OTHER ISSUES.
PEOPLE FAMILIAR WITH THE
INVESTIGATION SAYS THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN PROVIDING
DOCUMENTS TO MUELLER FOR MONTHS.
AN ATTORNEY AND A STATEMENT
SAYING "SINCE JULY 2017, WE HAVE
ADVISED THE PUBLIC THAT THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION IS FULLY
COOPERATIVE WITH ALL
INVESTIGATIONS, INCLUDING THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND IS
RESPONDING TO THEIR REQUEST.
THIS IS OLD NEWS AND OUR
ASSISTANCE AND COOPERATION WITH